well Prime Minister thank you very much
for coming along we've gotta start with
this this brain fade about the football
team you support is it west ham or Aston
Villa live out past a bit of an all my
life I don't know what happened I
literally open my mouth and I was going
off-piste about the fact you can in
Britain be a supporter of the West
Indies a supporter of mentioned United
and a sport of Team GB and I was then
busking about other things you could
support and I was I didn't happen to me
she's one of those things did always
stay no no I was going off script to set
out to add to the examples and I suppose
it's just the campaign but you by you
know by the time you made as many
speeches as I have on this campaign all
sorts of funny things done popping at
about God of our set started you know
they'll social media going especially
the football fan saying how can you
forget the football team you support
you'll forgive me just asking you a few
questions I'm not going to know what I
mean you must remember the european cup
final nice remember watching the
european cup final as a kid i do that's
why I when was it I became a bit of fact
I'm not doing quiz time because I'll get
them all wrong because but that's not
what I'm here to talk about the about
you one that's why I became a villa fan
because all by my uncle was involved in
the club back in the early eighties with
all those successes and andy gray and
brown little and that was what ya got me
going but i don't i don't go very often
in fact haven't been for years and years
but i try and keep up and I'm are you
hoping we're going to escape the
relegation zone which were out of now
and obviously I'm fabulous but you didn
t 2001 in the house that so you weren't
actually a football fan you think I mean
why I said I mean operate without your
regular at I'm not a regular attender I
used to play football as a kid my son
plays football and I try and sort of
keep up with what's happening in the
Premier League and see however are doing
but when they when they get snug in the
middle of the table I tend to sort of
but i tend to back off of it when we get
close to the bottom i get i get nervous
but I don't know what happened it's not
the most important issue but if your
team has won the European Cup only once
and you support it you'd know when it
was wouldn't you yes but I don't know if
you know where those early eighties I'm
not gonna give you a day cuz i'll get it
wrong and one goal and you know who
scored it you're wasting your precious
interview time okay it's not all that
space and it is it's meter with Prime
Minister let's talk about some the big
policy announcement then that your tax
cuts law for those on the minimum wage
you're saying it's your number
priority well what we're saying is that
we're saying in our queen speech it will
be if we're elected it will be all about
the economy because in the end the
economy isn't lines on a graph it is
people's jobs people's pay our strong
economy means our strong NHS a strong
economy means good schools a strong
economy means we can build their houses
that young people want to buy and own
for themselves it's at the heart of
everything it's a heart of the election
campaign and we're going to poke right
with that but are the exclusion of
everything else there are some pudding
aspect this this tax cut law for those
on the minimum wage namely the fact that
the tax-free threshold is ten thousand
six ten thousand six hundred it's going
to go to a thousand five hundred minutes
I've October the first you've announced
is going to be six pounds seven seven
year now when it's for those on 30 hours
a week which equals 201 pounds a week
201 pounds times I know this is
complicated but it's important it is
people on the minimum wage 201 pounds a
week times 52 is 10,000 452 pounds so
you're already getting that amount
that's what people need is a guarantee
that whatever happens to the minimum
wage and it's going to keep going up if
our economy keeps succeeding that you'll
always be outside the tax threshold no
matter how fast the minimum wage goes up
I want to see it so what you see is a
company you can't be trusted on a
promise so you have to pass legislation
so as you will keep your own pledge well
it's an absolute guarantee because what
might help I can't we take your word for
it well I'm giving you my word and a law
and also this will bind future
governments which i think is important
because otherwise you might have a
government that comes along that freezes
the tax threshold while the minimum wage
is increasing and draws people into
income tax but this is very important to
you but there's even more about this
though isn't it because of course it's
the lib dems idea originally you said in
the leaders debate in 2010 that raising
this tax threshold wouldn't work no I
did was to expense I said that I wanted
except i said i wanted to consider
unaffordable well i said i wanted to cut
taxes and this has been the right way to
cut taxes in this Parliament we've with
a conservative Chancellor and a
conservative Prime Minister we've taken
three million of the lowest paid people
out of tax altogether if we get to
12,500 pounds will take another million
people out of tax and this guarantee is
important because no matter how fast the
minimum wage rises we will
always have to keep lifting that tax
threshold to keep people outside those
on the minimum wage will not pay tax
they already don't pay the tax so you're
saying effectively vote for something
you already have it's like Arthur daily
selling some on their own I think
you're being ridiculous with respect
what it means is that you know if you're
on minimum wage and you work 30 hours a
week under the Conservatives you'll
never be dragged into the income tax net
that's an incredibly important guarantee
because that minimum wage is going to go
on increase the tax cut we are cutting
to it is a tax cut not know if you're on
the minimum wage because you're not
paying taxes attack a cut for 30 million
people because as we raise the tax
threshold from ten thousand six hundred
pounds to twelve thousand five hundred
pound that is a tax cut for 30 million
people it takes another million people
out of tax and it's a guarantee to
people on a minimum wage that no matter
what happens to the minimum wage you'll
never pay income tax though so great
virtual have the Duchess won't your
Prime Minister even on that 30 hours a
week on the minimum wage you will have
still have deductions by the state well
you have national insurance and such
like how much well I don't have the
figures off the top of my head but that
was very important to people it is every
pound counts because we we cut national
insurance because labor were proposing
the jobs tax and national insurance
increase when we got in five years ago
that was our first act was to stop that
jobs tax coming in to stop that national
insurance increase and we've got on and
cut national insurance so that if you're
an employer and you take on someone over
the air between 18 and 24 they pay no
national insurance whatsoever yes but
you can you tell someone who's working
30 hours on the minimum wage your number
one priority how much they will pay in
deductions to the state per year if you
thought this policy thrill are you
across it yes of course I well how much
will they pay I haven't got the figure
fort national insurance but the point is
where guarantee hundred an eighty seven
pounds a year but the key point is it is
only it's only the Conservatives that
can say to people that were not going to
put up national insurance we're not
going to put up income tax why because
we've said we're going to make the
savings in welfare in departmental
spending to get on top of our deficit
eradicate it all together whereas the
other parties are all saying they're
going to put up taxes so frankly the
question for me about national insurance
deductions is no one needs to worry
they're not going to go up under the
Conservatives because our plans are
fully paid for biggest
we're still learning not an awful lot of
money and the state is still taking some
of it does this illustrate this this
this this kind of policy that you
actually rather threadbare when it comes
to policies and that kind of no I tells
us more about the campaign that it's
rather lackluster you've heard that
accusation and it's negative I don't
accept that at all this is a very
positive policy what we're saying is
we're going to raise the personal tax
threshold we're going to raise the 50p
tax threshold for TP text threshold so
you don't start paying it till you're
earning 50,000 pounds we've got 30 hours
of free childcare for the parents of
three and four-year-olds these are all
about the same thing which is building a
strong economy very positive vision
where people who work hard and do the
right thing get rewarded and to me the
people talk about this campaign there's
nothing more positive than saying to
people let's get another two million
jobs let's fund another three million
apprenticeships let's let you keep more
of your own money to spend as you choose
let's build those homes that you want to
live in let's make sure there's good
schools for your children that is the
most positive vision there could
possibly be there's a security at every
stage of your life and that's what our
manifestos let's turn is MP though is it
positive continually attacking nicola
sturgeon and alex salmond has been
puppet masters and having had Miliband
in their top pocket and things like that
Nicola Sturgeon has been thanking you
for making them relevant and putting the
SNP said to stay too you're endangering
the union that I'm simply pointing out a
fact of this election which is it's
become apparent and you can ask any
expert that labor is likely to suffer
very badly at the hands of the SNP in
Scotland and that has consequences for
everyone in the rest of the country
because it means ed Miliband can only
form a government with the assistance of
the SNP now that I think is a very
disturbing development for our country
because the SNP don't come down to
Westminster to make our government
stronger or make our country stronger
they come down to Westminster to break
it up and I think it is the right and
responsible thing to point out the
dangers that are you angry about it are
you angry about that well it worries me
what would happen but the point is I
don't just make this as a observation I
have an answer which is there are only
23 more seats that conservatives need to
win to form an overall majority to stop
this from happening right you're not
going to win them in Scotland oh are you
and from the lodge hoping to yes we have
so you know we haven't we haven't argued
since we see we have a far get seats
you've got one in your mine on hold on
we have we have also other target seeds
but the blood is not crime minister the
problem is is not prime minister is that
post the referendum there is is that the
yes vote held together that's the SNP
and the novo cos obviously fractured the
pro-union vote you're all fighting
against each other there are four
thousand people a 400,000 people are
more who voted conservative in the last
general election if they voted for
pro-union parties you could do some
damage to the SNP I think the emerging
truth in Scotland is that if you want a
non socialist alternative to other
nationalist you want to break up our
United Kingdom only the Conservatives
can provide that option and that's why
in the recent polls in Scotland of
course the SMP are doing well but
actually the Conservatives are going up
we're a party of the United Kingdom in
fact we're the only party that stands in
a resale of you know always vote consent
although subsides if you've got a chance
to eat Alex Salmond out of parliament by
conservative voters lending the lib dem
candidate their vote you say no no vote
consider always vote conservative okay
well thank you very much indeed for that
let me move on to the issue of Libya and
what we heard from Ed Miliband the other
day that somehow British policy in Libya
has led or contributed in some part to
the crisis were seeing on the
Mediterranean do you accept that you
really didn't have a an endgame for
Libya after the military campaign you
didn't stand by Libya I don't accept
that we did stand by Libya and what I
did is a prime minister was make sure
that the new Libyan Prime Minister got
the help and the support he needed I
took him to the g8 summit which I
chaired in Northern Ireland got him
together with Barack Obama with the
leaders of France and Germany and Italy
we all pledged support we all pledged
aid Britain spent aid money in Libya
were still working to try and bring that
country back together to get the various
different groups into a national unity
government but I accept this hasn't
worked this hasn't been possible yet but
we're working at it but I would say to
people if you're asking for you know a
different approach do you mean we should
have put boots on the ground troops in
Libya after the end of the conflict I
think that would have actually made
matters even worse rather than better
but we need to keep going
perform that national unity government
what about the problem of the the track
the traffic is the criminal gang yes
they're involved I mean could you see
any form any form of military action
taking place against them at british
force has been annoy discussed in
brussels the meeting of the european
union potential action against these
traffickers everything would have to be
within international law you want to see
good levels of cooperation but if we can
do things to break up the gangs to get
rid of the boats to stop the criminals
involved it's not just military action
that's being being being looked at but
also criminal intelligence the
intelligence we have what more can we do
how can we work with the neighboring
countries to help stabilize them the
truth is there's no one single answer
search and rescue in the Mediterranean
which the British the Royal Navy will be
taking part of is one part of it but if
it was just that that wouldn't work you
need more now last question Prime
Minister about the Royal baby expected
any time maybe any hour any day now now
we know the NHS has served your family
so very well over the years it's so many
millions of families so you disappointed
that the royal family don't use the NHS
I think is a total matter of choice for
people what they use and where they have
the babies and all the rest of it all I
hope and pray for is that it'll be happy
healthy news for that wonderful couple
and for the whole country but is there a
danger that they there is a perception
then that the NHS isn't good enough for
the royal family well the NHS is superb
and I've seen that in my own life in so
many different ways but I believe in
choice I believe in people being able to
do what they want to do and as I say I
really got one thought about the Royal
baby which is a happy and healthy
arrival indeed Prime Minister thank you
very much pleasure to cameron legacy